how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
mcu and of course spider-man 3 because
the hype
is real so real that i normally don't
post on sundays but we have some
news today that comes in a form of a
rumor that is so exciting that i had to
do a quick
video on it so i could tell everybody
about this rumor
now this does come from a very trusted
source it comes from daniel
richmond's patreon where he stated that
wanda
maximoff and tony stark could be
in spider-man 3. now at this point
nothing is that surprising about
spider-man 3 almost everybody's going to
be in it but exactly how will robert
downey jr slash tony stark
return to appear in spider-man 3 and in
what capacity will he be in the film
after all he wasn't really in spider-man
far from home and that was the film
right after the movie where he died and
even though he wasn't in spider-man far
from home his presence was definitely
felt but i have a pretty good idea about
how robert downey jr and tony stark
are going to return in the film wanda
however seems pretty simple and doesn't
come as that big of a surprise
the president of marvel studios has
already stated that one division will
tie directly into spider-man 3
and then into doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness this even further
confirms the multiverse because why else
would wanda be in spider-man 3 if it
wouldn't have anything to do with what
happens in one division which we know
we're going to involve
different realities and since it leads
up to multiverse of madness that means
that some
sort of multiverse problem is going to
be happening in spider-man 3 which we
know at this point is going to be the
spider-verse
so that leads us to the question how
exactly is tony stark going to be
returning no he is not going to be
brought back from
the dead the tony stark and our main
universe that we know and love
is gone forever but there are an
infinite amount of
other universes where tony stark is
alive now in some universes he may not
be iron man but in a lot of them
he is and it's most likely one of these
versions of tony stark that we're going
to be seeing in spider-man 3.
after all the different peter parkers
that we're going to see are all going to
be
spider-man in their respective universe
so it would make sense that we would see
tony stark as
iron man from his respected universe now
if this does happen it's going to be
a major emotional scene for peter parker
r peter parker from the main mcu
timeline
especially in this moment in peter's
life he was just accused for the murder
of mysterio and the attack on many
different people throughout the world
his identity has been revealed and he's
wanted he's going to be in a tough place
so it's going to be extremely emotional
if he sees tony stark
however if he sees this tony stark from
another universe and this tony stark
does not know
who he is it's going to be even more
emotional for him
so what's going to be really interesting
is to see the capacity in which they
bring
this different tony stark from another
universe into the main mcu timeline to
interact with
our tom holland peter parker who really
hasn't had that much time to mourn the
loss of tony stark since far from home
happened right after end game
and spider-man 3 is picking up right
after the events of spider-man far from
home but i'm excited to see how they
throw in
tony stark from a different universe
into spider-man 3 and i'm excited to see
the interaction between him and
our peter parker let me know your
thoughts on this in the comments down
below and don't forget to subscribe so
you can stay up to date on all of the
latest spider-man 3 news
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof